are you really I met your husband
obviously a bunch of times in the same
family in fact he was the last person to
touch my wife's belly before we had our
I was there I was there
before we had our our first child no no
he died I think he like will didn't it
everybody's like 14 weeks pregnant
they're like oh no it was really sweet
and I'm always like no it's not he's
creepy you know in turn though I totally
creeped him out I ran into him at the
NFL owners and I was just so excited and
I didn't know I was gonna see him and I
was like oh I'm telling and then I sort
of acting weird so I left that's what I
did to you that is what I did to do when
you yes when you met Marilyn oh no you
did not because Oh scared of me no she's
not she's not look at how into eyes are
okay like I want to wear a skin oh my
god your eyes were burying today right I
didn't expect it to happen yell I'm not
around actors ever until now this show
but like I'm never at each other our
musicians it was it's actually a thing
of beauty because I was walking this way
and I didn't realize that Meryl was over
here how I don't even know but you were
here and not your eyes were saucers and
I was like oh my god it's Kelly and for
a minute I thought you were like eyes
were saucers for me I was like
[Applause]
Clarkson and usually you turn to me
you're like I just made Merrill I don't
remember I blacked out and then I
proceeded to blackout are we both blob
like now I was like I mean poor other
girls it would they were just sitting
there and I was like in Merrill no I
actually have met her in black as well
told me I was annoying because she
thought it would play that I was in and
she meant it is it a compliment but the
first words ever from Meryl Streep oh my
god so annoying good job she saw me in a
play that's a therapy that's what we
heard about the knee gash and the whole
thing and the dumplings and so see it
ended well oh my gosh you said that
sterling your husband freaks people out
I freaked him out just he probably
remember or maybe he's like don't get me
or Kelly Clarkson oh never say that he'd
never see was as he would say don't you
embarrass me on that Kelly Clarkson show
very similar like you're both like that
I love yes we should I love you too and
we should go out but not anywhere where
there's like a lot of people yeah like
places that you get all those people
going you're annoying
[Laughter]
yes so we have so much fun here who's
gonna call you mate Meryl is gonna call
us and want to hang but I'm gonna
use a phone about you do you think maybe
she's one of those people that no one
ever calls her because everybody thinks
that they're not cool enough for Meryl
and she's like really super lonely and
just waiting for you lolly she's got
like a big family I think she got a lot
of kids and so I shouldn't ever dream
but wait you've got a new a new show out
First Wives Club
yeah and I'm be cheap like after seeing
the movie like friends that we all
they're like four friends we all got a
little pearl necklace it's just like I
love that movie it still is it based on
that
the movie it is and I have to say they
did a really really good job because you
know reboots can sometimes feel like
retreads of like the same but what they
did was they took the like energy and
the excitement and the love that
everybody has for that movie admittedly
so and then they just kind of use it as
a backdrop and there's Easter eggs but
really it's a it's an homage to the
movie as opposed to like you know a
reboot so yeah it's it's really smartly
done I'm excited about the original cast
of first Wes Club I hear you ran into
Goldie Hawn which is awesome I would
have just started saying lines from Bird
on a Wire like all the films from my
childhood because they do well with
meeting icons though I don't know if
you've noticed it was a good thing we
weren't there together first of all it's
embarrassing because I was at the
psychics you're at a psychic I kick okay
I'd kick I was at the psychic everything
is gonna work out in my life you know
and I guess Goldie want to know that
everything's gonna work out in her life
and it was right when the wind cated had
the next her third baby the little girl
and I like to think the door opened and
there she was and I was like I know my
psychic isn't over huh
wait I think so amazing like that's
where I'm I'm I our brains right heaven
in I just I realized she wasn't the
psychic and I was like oh my god what
did she do she did this she was like
yeah that's kind of how I feel Merrill
got scared of me I was loud though she
should have been Scott was excited I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this